taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them hey Tasties welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buzz we're here with a great
episode we got my buddy esoteric in the
house from Zara face the mighty Czar
face here to represent how's it going
[Laughter]
that's the way you hold the mic it's
much like uh yeah but I'm not on stage
you know podcast environment
oh that's not how you hold it on stage
no on stage I cuff it which is
not supposed to do this because it's
just the the LL
you're not supposed to because it's just
it distorts or like so yeah yeah but I
never noticed it but of course I'm
rapping at the people and they're just
if their hands are up everything's good
yeah they're just looking everything
because that that hold you had I thought
looked like a like an experienced hole
okay yeah yeah sure I'll take that I do
this whenever if I'm attempting to rap
uh I will tell you I went to I went to
uh the 50th 50th Anniversary turning at
Radio shitty you went yeah
yeah all right you couldn't go you were
away I know I couldn't go but I didn't
know you went I went with Jay I went
with Ari
just you do me it already got free
tickets we were in the fifth row
do you have free tickets in the fifth
round I got a hook up we
will you hooked it up he knows somebody
over at Radio City probably the person
you know over at Radio City free tickets
fifth row Jay had to pay for his ticket
he went to yeah I missed out uh I don't
wanna I
want you to ask you this is one of the
greatest nights
start to finish the whole thing I met
PMD outside for me PMD it was one of the
greatest nights of my life it was one of
the best concerts I've ever seen I was I
was on my feet dancing for three hours
like it was hit after hit after hit
there's a similar lineup for rock the
bells uh but uh no I can't get to that
either I'm going to rock the Bell I've
heard enough let's just move on you
can't go
rock the bells is the day before my
birthday I'm going for my birthday full
everything whole ride why don't you come
we mean whole ride what does that mean
the we're gonna get the traits on the
arm we're getting the treatment how'd
you get that I got a hook where is that
one again Forest Hills Forest Hill
you're out of town for that I'm in Long
Island I looked at the two-hour drive
I'll see what don't go to Long Island it
was it the sixth the fifth
buddy I'm telling you that's going to be
a day I'll see what I can do please I'll
see what I can maybe maybe one of your
best Pals it's his birthday please come
on anyway sorry
hey he just met PMD that's why he's
saying I'm calling you from day one yeah
I roll with him I'm like you know Joe
derosi calls me e do not like it no it's
cool
Mighty oh yeah you know him yeah I know
yeah this is what I was going to say
about the cup and the mic yeah some of
the guys cut the mic yep and it was very
hard to hear what they were saying and
it hurt the
sound two guys that didn't and I was
like this is why these two guys are
masters with KRS and Big Daddy Kane oh
yeah you could hear every word it's a
nice that's a nice shot fired at you
sorry
but you know what because rappers
example he's trying to examples trying
to tell you yeah that uh how how to do
your job get him ready for the battle
let me know you are you are a failed
not to run
we don't want KRS or Big Daddy gang gets
on taste buds and then
yeah
I know you collect tapes so I wanted to
give you why would you give away an
original can I see Ultra magnification I
figured you'd appreciate it man wow I
absolutely do I just can't believe you'd
want to part with it look at this this
Champion right here it's great this is
king among men it's a good kid you
literally criticize him and he hands you
a gift we're here to battle buddy you
know so yeah actually that's what I'm
doing I'm buttering him up
yeah exactly I just did showing my other
podcast uh we'll see you in hell we did
a q a episode yesterday and one of the
questions was name three underrated
albums my first one was Run DMC Tougher
Than Leather my second one was
Ultramagnetic MC's critical Beatdown oh
there we go I have several copies of
this album I think it is a give it back
to me what
[Applause]
having another I'm just dead serious
this album is to me is is a landmark I
mean absolutely describe how much I
think that's one of my favorite records
ever
um from one of my favorite groups ever
that's awesome buddy and uh bizarre face
let's talk about Czarface
yeah sure let's fill up some time I
first okay now I first heard you're from
Boston right yeah that's where you're
from originally okay Czarface I was in
Amoeba Records in L.A when I lived in
L.A right sure I'm in the I I would do a
thing where if I saw something that
looked cool enough I would just buy it
and I saw the first starface album
and it had this cool like comic bookie
cover
and I was like Czar face what is this
and it said featuring esoteric
and at the time I was not familiar with
you yet and then it said also featuring
inspector deck of Wu-Tang Clan the rebel
ins yes and I was like well inspector
Jack's my favorite member Wu-Tang Clan I
was like I'm just gonna buy this like
this looks awesome there's a lot of
people's number one MCA he's amazing I
don't know who thinks that right so I
buy it I put I haven't heard one track
I don't think it was streaming at the
time I in fact this is still when iTunes
was like the thing was pre-apple music
yeah I threw it in my car as soon as I
got in the car because I was so curious
immediately I was like this is a what in
God's name and I was like and this other
guy esoteric is awesome and I was like
what is this this is amazing right cut
to so I become obsessed with the record
then they put a second record out and
I'm like excited for it now because I'm
a legit fan sure and I download it the
day it comes out and everything then I
do Dean Del Rey's podcast sure I've done
that let there be talk yes where he goes
I want to talk to you about a band that
you're really into and whatever during
one segment and he goes who who are you
into that you feel like you know like
maybe maybe not a lot of people know
about or maybe they do but it's like
underground or whatever and or you know
modern band that you love whatever it is
you know new Cutting Edge and I said
well there's this rap group named
Czarface and I was like dude they're
nuts they only have two records out but
they're both incredible and I was like
inspector deck from wu-tangs
this this guy 7l does all the beats and
this guy's a terrorism and he's awesome
and I was like man it's they're they're
incredible
and I forget about it
Dean tweets that the episode comes out
right right and he's like hey the
episode's out can you retweet oh yeah I
retweet it I'm I'm I'm jogging because
it's back when I exercise in LA and I
look at my phone
I wanted to pay a parking meetings I was
running I was right
uh I I I I'd stop to take a breath and I
look at my phone I open Twitter and I
got a tweet from him that's cool and
he's like
hey man thanks for the shout out he goes
next time I see you KFC's on me uh I'll
roll under the gate with you which was a
punch line to a joke I had about KFC I'm
like this guy knows to stand up and is
quoting it to me yeah no way yeah yeah
that's how it went down oh so you
knew who he was yeah I did I didn't do
his material yeah so it worked out I was
like that's why I was like oh wow when I
heard it because I didn't hear the
podcast as as it happened somebody
tagged me in it right and then I then I
heard it and I was like oh wow I know
this guy dude I freaked out yeah I
freaked out because the thing that I've
been most interested in in being in
comedy has always been to get to meet
people I admire and artists I admire and
I've we we meet Comics that's all you
meet is Comics you're we're in comedy so
so when the idea of like meeting
musicians and stuff that you admire I
was like that would be the coolest thing
because I have no link to the world and
um
and you were the first ever I remember
calling my friend Jim and telling him
like but you were the first ever like
guy that I connected to like artists
that I admired from afar that I actually
made a connection I was like he knows
who I am that's crazy and like and then
we became uh we he came to my show in
Boston
then I went to see you with Vinnie Paz
at the um uh fat beats anniversary the
25th anniversary yeah yeah and I was on
a first date that's right I walk in this
guy towel oh the dates the first date
take it easy take it easy
[Laughter]
you leave them wanting more it's a first
Roll Show Business yeah yeah you left
the wake of girls wanting more hold on
okay take it easy all right listen so
um
I get to Sony Hall Tau who eventually
worked at Joey roses and it was a friend
of mine from the comedy seller I didn't
even know he worked at Sony Hall he's
like DeRosa what are you doing here I'm
like coming to see the uh the fat Beach
show I go you know esoteric and he goes
yeah I go he put me on the list
so I'm already on the list sorry to look
cool tell's like oh dude come on I got
you takes me and this girl gives us like
the most VIP table with tables amazing
I'm like I look like the man right now
he goes on stage shouts me out
and there wasn't a second date dad
brings us there was a second date then
brings us backstage after the show we're
hanging out backstage
we're meeting the other rappers
then he goes I heard there's an after
party
um with Dayla
and I go yeah there's a Chappelle thing
happening and he goes it's the same
thing I go oh cool so we go we go in she
sees him talking to De La Soul she sees
that I know Chappelle I pull her side at
one point I go it will never be like
this ever again
it was the craziest night but that was
the night where I was like I like I was
like I felt like you and I became we
were friendly but I was like we became
like friends that night but then you
took me with static selector yes to that
bar and we drank yes and I felt like he
didn't like me very much but we drink
yeah
a great guy I'm sure he liked you I
don't know all right very cool I wasn't
paying attention to New York Chemistry I
was paying attention to your Chemistry
with the girl which sends fizzled I
think we we haven't spoken
no no it didn't it didn't move forward
but we had all De La Soul Vib treatment
it was all that couldn't pull it off for
you huh
I need a lot of assists
you got Richard Pryor
I'm like Ted McKinley on Happy Days and
then and then get DJ a cool herc and
that would have done it
um but it was it was wild but but we've
been we've been friends ever since and
like you know I don't obviously I don't
say it because we're friends I admired
him before we were friends but yeah just
the the work this guy does man in and
outside of Czarface is just truly truly
incredible I I every time somebody asked
me who contemporary and Hip-Hop do you
like that you're the first group I say
every time
how did you um I mean excuse me that
you've probably asked this a billion
times how did you come up uh how did you
get into this how'd you come up and how
did you link up with inspected
um well we uh we made a record with
inspect the deck in like 99 see I was a
we had a we were a Duo 7 Ln esoteric I
was the mc7l was a DJ and producer and
we wanted to do we had the same manager
as deck I'm not saying manager is deck
the same guy who worked at loud records
which was Dex label so he could connect
us with deck that way okay and then uh
we asked him about a collaboration
collabs in 98 99 were a little more rare
than they are now you know what I mean
so we were able to get that done record
it in Brooklyn one day deck came through
with street life and a couple of other
guys oh wow really he was open to it he
was cool yeah oh yeah he's very cool man
we just we ordered a couple pizzas we
sat down uh you know surrounded by vinyl
at my man's Studio like it was a
makeshift Studio at the time and um yeah
that came in he ate pizza he wrote his
verse in about seven minutes and just
went out and recorded it in about 30
seconds and I I just I was just in awe
because I didn't know him yet you know
what I mean he was still a hero to me
right still you know one of my favorite
MCS ever but at that point this was you
know not my friend this was right like
an idol you know what I mean and uh so
we recorded that in 99 and then years
passed we kept in touch we shopped beats
to him and he get he sent some verses
for just some you know more underground
stuff and then seven L had this idea
like hey why don't we do a whole album
with inspect the deck and I said you're
crazy because that's never going to
happen and uh but deck said he was down
he's down to do an album so then then
was he now now let me ask you was he
down to do the record
because he was like hey I had a good
experience working with you guys that
one time like so why not or was he like
no man I'm I'm like into you guys like
let's do this like yeah I feel like I
feel like what if it's the former well I
think either is fine I feel like you
know what you're saying the same thing
yeah yeah right you're like you said did
he want to do the record because you're
a good guy or because you're a good
rapper no did he know you I guess what
I'm asking is is did he know the work
you guys were doing outside of the song
you collaborated on do you know what I'm
saying like you're able to keep in touch
throughout this because you know what I
mean to me that's huge right you're
talking about your idol who's now like
no I familiarize myself with your work
now yeah and like let's do this yeah
absolutely yeah so he knew my my prior
work you know what I mean he knew my
name was Heavy in the streets you know
what I'm saying and uh we were able to
uh come up with we made a couple songs
and then I was like wow we gotta start
coming up with an idea name for this
group and deck suggested uh the bomb
text like bomb technicians which sounded
cool but it to me it sounded like a
little bit 290s for for what we were
trying to do right and I I just had this
idea for a character as to lead the lead
the charge you know what I mean sort of
like Eddie with Iron Maiden or whatever
and and
um we came up with zarface and it just
became this uh
thing that I could engage my son with as
I was raising my son because he'd be in
the back of the car while I'm listening
to beats and he's always like needing
something because he was four or five at
that time and to get him to kind of
Listen and play along and let me kind of
listen to the music and create Rhymes as
I'm driving I'd have to tell him oh this
is like the Magneto beat or the ultimate
null of fire beat or the the just the
the Stormtrooper because he loved all
the Marvel DC Star Wars stuff so as long
as he could engage with the music under
the the identity of like the Green
Lantern track or something I would be
able to work on the music and then I was
like wow we should do something with
like this superhero character and then
zarface came about that's so cool it's
very very cool and all the you know it's
it's
the music itself
like you know the things that hooked me
early were like there it was it was like
this they're they're sampling the right
stuff and when they're not sampling The
Right Stuff they're making things sound
like they're sampled which to me was a
brilliant approach no we can make it
sound like we dug this off of some old
record we're just going to EQ it in a
certain way and which is brilliant and
then
all this all the snippet and
interstitial stuff like they they're
sampling like old wrestling promos and
like that's so you know like YouTube toy
collectors and stuff like that like I I
just was like man these guys are like
scratching all the itches yeah yeah yeah
and I think a lot of the stuff that we
all came up listening to like bomb squad
production for Public Enemy or you know
said g alternate almost had littered
little sound bites into the music at the
time too and those are some of the
things I I call right back to and stuff
that I love Growing Up So sampling a
random thing from YouTube from you know
an obscure toy review or something it's
flavorful for me it engages me well you
know not that I listen to my own records
but once once the record's done it's out
and I don't listen to it back I can't
stand the because I always find an
imperfection with it sure I just let it
go but but it's creating it it's fun
sorry no no don't be sorry the bomb
squad stuff the approach you know I'm a
big uh I'm a big Zappa fan and like
Zappa
he's got a lot of Records where he does
this and the hip-hop albums that mirror
what I'm the technique I'm talking about
I always call it sound collage like
it's a barrage you hit play and it never
stops until the last note there's never
a moment of silence and like so PE does
that on especially Fear of a Black
Planet uh Dre does that on the second
NWA record uh he does it on The Chronic
um you guys do that where it's just like
Zappa we're only in it for the money is
the best example but like Zappa would
take people and he would he would he's
got these weird interstitials where he
put a microphone inside of a piano and
he would tell his friends he would go go
sit under the piano and just sit there
and talk and he would record it and then
he would just take Snippets from the
conversation and put it with sound
effects and it would be like in this
weird thing and then
that was exactly the same thing you guys
were doing where I was like oh it's like
barreling out of this song into this
weird clip of a guy that's on YouTube
talking about some action figure yeah
and there's been a few times where
they've actually they've been connected
to it through somebody hey these guys
sampled your voice and they you know
people were thrilled about it you know
and then all of a sudden I'm like yeah
yeah let me send you the record and it
just becomes a relationship that way and
well the thing on the first record that
killed me was you go
you go uh I'm watching Jim Gaffigan with
the fattest Grand and I was like oh yeah
this guy likes Jim Gaffigan that's funny
and then yeah and then uh I was like
that's such a weird reference in a rap
song this is so crazy these guys are
like comedy fans I guess and then you
reference Segura yeah and the Zagora
shot the video with you right yes yeah
yeah that was much more recent that was
more recent that was maybe 2018 19 maybe
it was right before the pandemic it was
a track from the what the third album
now yeah third or fourth from the the
odds are against us okay the song the
track was called Bizarro and uh I said
uh something about Saucony Azura
catch me on your mom's house what up Tom
Segura and that led to uh you know Tom
just being really cool and uh being down
to be in the video
and then we wound up putting out a
Czarface Azura Saucony Azura with
Saucony so that line kind of oh that's
so cool it kind of built two
relationships and it didn't you know it
wasn't intended it's just Azura and
Segura Rhymes it was a convenient
situation connected with both of them
with that one line
damn that's crazy yeah it was just one
of these things and then uh you know
Tommy brought us out to do a show in
Austin and uh we wound up performing
there and it was it was cool it was
great yeah you saw that I saw the the
backstage stuff Yeah from Austin that's
very cool man yeah that's very very who
else did you come up I'm trying to think
of in late 90s I was listening to some
underground stuff
um I'm just trying to think of the cage
yeah yeah cage no cage you know cage
copyright maybe yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I know those guys it's been a minute
because I got into high and mighty a
friend of mine knew Eric I guess yeah
yeah yeah and uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's great yeah are they Canada Philly
no yes Philly yeah
I saw a cage I thought those guys were
from uh like the Toronto scene with like
smut Peddlers and all them Peddlers is
them yeah wait spotlighters are Philly
well well it's Eon yeah it's Eon cage
right oh no who is it I think so that's
right cage is smart Peddler but I didn't
know they were Philly yeah I thought
they were from like but I mean I think
when they're making the members you know
they're Swollen Members is from
Vancouver or Rick Hoover yeah yeah sure
is that the crop of people like that
were like yeah yeah we're all I guess
from the same class same age group yeah
yeah
um and I think are those guys still
still doing it I think so yeah yeah I
think so uh um folks game time game time
game time I love going to events I like
going to events without a big commitment
in advance I like making last minute
decisions when I want to go to events I
want to know I can get the best tickets
available at that time in that last
minute moment for the event that's why I
love game time that's what the game
timeout does and I think a lot of people
fall right on the same uh scenario for
you you could buy tickets to your
favorite events last minute they
guarantee the prices you could see where
you're sitting directly from your seat
they have Flash Deals
um literally comedy Sports uh you know
concerts they have every kind of thing
there's event cancellation protection
um there's just no reason not to try it
especially if you're looking for
something to do and a lot of times we
associate getting tickets oh we don't
have them the things tonight we can't go
not with game time also game time
guarantee they have a game time
guarantee that means you're going to get
the best price if you find tickets in
the same section in row for less money
game time will credit you 110 of that
difference so here's what I want you to
do I want you to snag those tickets
without the stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use taste buds that's the
code for twenty dollars off your first
purchase terms apply again create an
account redeem the code taste buds for
twenty dollars off download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed
this this show is sponsored by
betterhelp
folks I love better help I've had times
in my life where I have felt uncertain
where I felt that my footing was not
firm where I felt that the ground
underneath my feet was not stable I mean
that's how I feel every single day and
especially in our profession you're
always uncertain about things about your
path forward making decisions around
your career your relationships anything
else therapy actually helps you stay
connected to what you really want and
helps you to navigate life right I want
to speak from the heart here I have my
hand in many different types of work
different types of businesses none of
them are what you would call traditional
or by definition stable
and I can't tell you the comfort and
assistance that better help has brought
me through my conversations with my
therapist in allowing me the convenience
to speak to him when I need to and
allowing me the access to a person that
can help me when I need it and allowing
me to figure out how to focus on problem
solving instead of focusing on the
problems themselves you heard it here
really and you guys if you if you're our
fans you know that we need therapy so
that's a loud endorsement right there if
you're looking at starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
it's designed to be convenient flexible
suited to your schedule fill out the
brief questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime no additional charge let therapy
be your map with better help visit
betterhelp.com tastebuds today to get 10
off your first month that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p betterhelp
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com slash taste buds
if you're listening to this right now
and you are a natural I am here I'm
playing the opera house tonight with the
guys
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets
tomorrow we will be in uh the Cambridge
Field House in Indianapolis and we're
rounding out Saturday at the stifle
theater in St Louis for two shows grab
those but I am back on tour after that
because I'm filming my special in
Chicago in December and we are going to
be at the Hartford Funny Bone the
Syracuse Funny Bone the Albany Funny
Bone all by September and then we're
hitting Bowling Green Kentucky
Cincinnati Toledo Wilkes-Barre
Pennsylvania Wilmington
Macon Georgia which I was corrected
about many times Savannah Athens Georgia
I'm coming through you Mount Pleasant uh
there you go and then Peoria Rockford
Cedar Rapids Springfield Illinois Duluth
Minnesota Appleton Wisconsin which just
went on sale so you get those tickets to
still good ones Rochester Davenport and
Elkhart Indiana they're all on sale
right now they're all going to be before
the end of this year
salvolcano comedy.com for tickets and
you know what check out some hey babe
and uh some taste buds merch on our
website we got some good merch so you
should go there if you're a fan and buy
something don't be I have got a big fall
tour coming up big venues big shows big
fun Avenal New Jersey September 16th
Toronto Ontario September 21st through
the 23rd November 11th Philadelphia PA
my hometown at the old TLA oh classic
November 17th Pittsburgh PA bottle
rocket Social Hall November 18th in
Buffalo New York November 30th Denver
Colorado defense December 1st in Phoenix
December 3rd in Salt Lake City and more
dates are being added all the time go to
jodarosa.com for ticket and venue
information and ticket links I want to
see you out there please people also
guess what the album salsa windfall
artificial birth available everywhere on
August 1st and if you want to buy it you
can go buy it over at Bandcamp Camp it's
dropping August 1st on band camp a
little early so you can buy it at a
discounted rate and then it hits all the
Digital streaming platforms on August
4th I know you've been waiting for it
I'm excited about it I hope you are too
salsa windfall artificial birth hitting
those streets the first week of August
right in time for my birthday also if
you're in New York City please come to
Joey roses we're open seven days a week
starting at 11 30 a.m every day you love
those sandwiches you love those drinks
why don't you love them together Joey
roses joeyrosesnyc.com
so uh in that uh era I think is when
we're all kind of sharpening our our
swords you know what I'm saying and
um
I think now a kind of uh I got a
wolverine adamantium type of I'm trying
to transition
yeah that's very good no we're battling
yeah we're battling Wolverine versus
Batman I'm sorry go no no no just
remembering one of their albums that
might have been the second album but I
think they got Eminem on a track
actually yeah they did yeah yeah it was
that Arrow when Eminem was just he was
just breaking before he was Eminem yeah
but he was still like Eminem yeah and
it's a law like back then it was anyway
it was a lot like all the other white
rappers are like who the is this
Eminem guy yeah it was like Eminem yeah
and then you hear Eminem oh okay all
right I still oh good good no no no no
no no no no no please finish oh I was
just saying that they yeah they managed
to do a joint with them right before or
maybe it was during the day right but
before the album came out you know what
I mean yes and he was a he had a did you
have a cross path with him yeah yeah
actually I met him
um the first time I met my wife which
sounds funny yeah it's the same same
night different spots but they were
doing a Lyricist Lounge tour in Boston
so I remember the exact date because I
have the stuff from the show and I was
at the show so it was it's it's a way
it's a funny thing because it's like
okay I'm at my you know Andrea yeah you
know and yeah so I met Eminem yeah the
only thing I had on him was height you
know what I'm saying
it's funny because
any man right I think that's the high
Mighty Eminem song Any Man Who jump
inside of a minivan yeah yeah yeah yeah
maybe I'm wrong uh but but uh
I saw um for a nice size word to my son
left yeah I'm like the Bulls in that
I love that I got you guys rapping
man
looking more from the Frog guys go
uptown Eureka's eating Taco Bell saying
Viva gorditas all your dogs I'll
give them rabies they never had a chance
like my two aborted babies yeah all
right gotta Pope John Paul II praying to
Satan got your vegan girlfriend cooking
up bacon
that's Eon okay and comes in right after
that okay oh that's what I was gonna say
I remember the first time I saw Eminem I
was I was still rapping I was in college
and I was still trying to I thought
that's what I was going to do and um I
saw the video I was away I was a theater
Miner we were away at a theater
conference for theater kids and we were
in the hotel room we had MTV on and the
my name is video came on
and I remember I was so mad because I
was just like
Dr Drake co-signed this what is
this because because it was such like a
comedy song and then my friend was like
yo I got the album he's no joke and I
was like that's like a joke it's like
Weird Al and he was like no no
trust me and then he played it for me
and I was like oh wow that's a song that
broke him right isn't that crazy yeah
yeah yeah it's like nothing else sounds
like that no no and it's it's um
sometimes it takes somebody like Dre to
really put you through the glass ceiling
and obviously he shattered he's on
another planet yeah um but yeah at that
time a lot of people were scratching
their heads like you just like what the
as soon as the second album hit and
I heard kill you I was like this dude is
a is one of the greats I was like this
is nuts how good he is but he but oh
Prince Paul speaking of
hey
he sent me the cassettes okay shout outs
principles so let's give them just a
little case they didn't see that we had
principal legendary hip-hop producer uh
Prince Paul on the cast and then Joe
was telling him how he used to rap and
then he he requested of you to send him
he said something well he didn't want
the legitimate rap he wanted the comedy
wrap I did that was sex rap
uh the band was called Deep okay and he
said I will send you a box of cassettes
if you send me a signed copy of Deep
so I texted him he got he sent the
cassettes immediately he's awesome he's
the man love you yeah and I was like all
right Paul I I I I'll send you the CD I
was nervous because because I said on
the show
I wouldn't have sent it
Prince Paul I I know it's royalty I was
it's the guy they're descended for that
I was scared to send it because I was
like this is something that would get me
like in theory could get me
harsh humor but he's really I wonder if
what he said I want to know if it's
so let's see what he said I signed it in
I signed the CD in character okay
I signed it as the two characters I
played I autographed it I I taped an ace
of hearts card to the front of the CD
and I wrote on it
I wrote
to to the to the prince
uh you know from or I don't know from to
the prince or the king or something
whatever they said and then I said uh I
said we stopped chasing hoes long enough
to sign this CD for you love uh Jay Beto
and Bernard which is the two characters
I played and then I said it to him and I
was and I texted him and I go as
promised I sent you the CD it is
autographed in character
please do not get me canceled yeah
because of the content it was done in
great irony
right I'm worried about his opinion
he goes dude I'm too old to get anybody
canceled don't worry about it all right
he goes and then that was it and then
and then I was like by the way I love
the cassettes blah blah wait wait so he
didn't respond about listening to it I'm
getting to it oh okay hold on oh you're
taking them
scenic route
you have a battle to do that we're on
the plane Joe land the plane he likes to
get he likes to get Lippy when there's a
guest he likes to show up for company
yeah anyway
so then I want to hear about a
week later later he texts me yeah
and he goes I got the CD it's all
exclamation he's like excited and I'm
like okay uh he goes listen I gotta hit
the road for a couple weeks but I'm
gonna listen as soon as I get back okay
cool in my head I'm like please just
never listen to it please just never
listen to it dude a full month and a
half goes by I'm like not only has he
listened to it he hates it and he's not
and maybe he is going to get me canceled
I don't know what's going on here right
and I was I swear on my mother's life
the day I was about to text him and I
was going to write to him Paul your
silence means one of three things either
a you hate it B you're going to be
canceled or C you're so blown away by
the quality you can't how to say the day
I was going to send that text my phone
buzzes I look and it's him and he's just
goes yo the CD is mad funny and I was
like
Paul
I gotta be honest I'm very relieved that
you just wrote that to me and he goes
bro thank you for the laughs man yeah
it's funny man and I was like I'm glad
we can make you laugh when are you in
New York he's like I'm coming up in I
think obviously let's you know I'm like
great cool I hope to see you man yeah
and that was it so all went well okay
I'm not going to get signed over it but
you're not going to get canceled I'm not
going to get cancer and he laughed which
was the point it was supposed to be
funny he left that was the key I credit
him with keeping us on a path of making
music so in 96 we went to rock steady
park for Rocksteady anniversary and
Prince Paul was there and I had the
audacity to hand him our record vinyl at
that time I mean we're still doing vinyl
now obviously but it was like a 12 inch
and I gave it to principal and had the
800 number to call us on the label and I
was like
I'm like nervous giving it to him you
know and he'll never uh respond but the
fact that he's taking it from me means
something sure sure and then he called
him it was a like a beeper thing where
you could leave a voice message at that
time you know just an 800 number to
leave a voice message that's how I went
and he left the message he's like yo I
checked out the recommend it's dope and
I'm like that's Prince Paul's voice did
you take that and throw it on another I
wish I still had it man like 96 97
didn't have that technology I don't
think you know what's weird though in
the box of stuff he sent me that was
shoved in there I don't know
I mean if we put him right here to a lie
detector test he probably wouldn't
remember but
he said the story he showed us how much
of a great guy he goes there's going to
be some bad stuff in that box that I
sent you and I was like how bad could it
be one of the things was the Mo Money
soundtrack
I was like okay yeah you were there were
a couple doozies in here but uh that's
great that he called you buddy that's
awesome that's so awesome the uh
and so e esoteric Tarik
maybe you just call him Rick uh
uh he's the man he's here today we're
here to battle
uh we I knew he was a comic book guy I
put my foot in my mouth the other day I
texted him and I go you want to battle a
comic book thing and he goes yeah I go
DC Marvel would be good I go because bro
I Marvel and then he doesn't respond and
I'm sitting there and I go
he did a comic book with Marvel oh
doesn't mean you hate him I should have
said that that I remembered that they
did a song on the Venom soundtrack and I
was like oh yeah that's right yeah
I was like God damn it and then I start
texting him I'm like dude I was just
kidding Marvel I like the comic some of
them
oh you know how it is sometimes you just
don't have your phone ready to go and
then it happens to me too I'll text
somebody and then like a day I'll go by
I'm like what did I do oh dude every day
all day what are you reading the text I
couldn't have offended anyone that's why
I started leaving voice notes because
you can hear the inflection yeah I know
it's coming from you know what I mean
like oh that's all we do is voice okay
all right cool bro bro I'll start
loading you with the voice notes
and put them on a record huh I said
don't open that box we try to beat each
other's record of length of messages oh
really yeah I've left him a voice
message that was like 14 minutes oh he
texted me once at some point like why
are we talking about he texted me once
when we first started doing it we were
legitimately excited he goes bro I'm in
a Walmart but I can't wait to get in the
car and listen to this four and a half
minute Banger you just yeah I think I
was like doing Kobe I was like doing
Kobe and I was like we would just be
like oh four minutes it was like you had
an episode of TV watch or something
so hot and cold with I know
so you threw out a bunch of things you
threw out like Marvel vs DC Justice
League versus X-Men like what what have
you but then you threw out something I
thought was even cooler because it was
more pointed yeah and that's today's
battle which is who is the bigger badass
Batman and Wolverine which I think if
I'm just thinking of in the Rolodex of
superheroes they're at the top of the
list of badasses I mean yeah maybe it's
um it's everyone's a badass but you know
like yeah yeah it's the two guys it's
like two guys that are in their 40s
Wolverine Batman are usually portrayed
to be in their 40s they're still out
there kicking ass
they're still right I wrote a sketch
once for an SNL packet about Wolverine
well actually I'm gonna save this for
the battle but they're two guys in their
40s that are still out there kind of
kicking ass and doing things and and
they're questionable badasses they're
not quite anti-heroes but they're
questionable sure they have questionable
methods yes you know and that's become
now a running joke in Marvel and DC I
think more so in DC about Batman yeah
which Q gets real upset about all the
jokes about how Batman's a fascist now
and all this stuff really cute doesn't
care for those those jokes uh but uh but
um
I I I would imagine there's probably
similar jokes being made now about
Wolverine and Marvel about how he's kind
of like
you know what's with this guy he seems a
little uh who's taking what today well
uh I'm taking let's make it clear that I
love both okay but I I am uh I'm taking
Wolverine okay I'm rocking Wolverines
yeah yeah wherever he is and I don't
know what what if you don't have any
Batman shirts to rock or anything
nothing I don't need to wear a shirt to
win a battle all right let's do this
that's the attitude you need on the mic
man yeah
oh I'm here to say I don't need a Batman
t-shirt what did you hear I heard the
prince Paul episode You spit a little
couplet that was dope I did it was good
you know something about uh are you
really do you really think it was though
yeah
it was a good it was a good rhyme like a
multi-syllabic rhyme structure which was
great it wasn't the Fred Flintstone rap
it was something that was more remember
I sent you that beat
yeah he sent me a beat in a Star Wars
beat and it's you know it's it's great
because Star Wars is my I know I sent it
to you yeah no and I love it but is it I
just don't want to get sued by you know
put it out for free they can't show us
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well maybe get
around to it in the fourth year after I
sent it to you listen folks
here's a beat I made once he goes I love
it I go great never heard anything
but the arrogance to think that he wants
to rap with you I don't know he did he
did a he was doing all kinds of stuff he
filmed a video on his YouTube
you didn't take the four years of radio
silence as a hint I don't know yeah a
little bit of a hint that should be the
name of that should be what you wrap
over that Beat radio silence is the name
of the track it should be called that's
a great title for a track radio shines
he is a very nice guy I feel like he is
a nice enough guy where he wouldn't tell
you like dude I don't like it but you
did tell me they were sampling John
Williams how can't I like it okay it's
like you're you're looping Perfection
yeah you know what I'm saying and it's
like oh wow I mean this is great it hits
me right here you already here first
folks she's gonna do it
I'm gonna do it yeah he's just getting
principal to add a few touches to it
we'll uh try on for it uh okay can I
tell you where I see this going yeah so
I think just I think you would agree
Batman is the bigger name of the two and
probably more widely known to the
non-comic book Aficionado so there is
some weight that comes along with you
choosing Batman here but I will say I
think the
The Lion's Share of people probably
understand who they both are and I think
you're going to get a lot of I think
Wolverine's gonna win and I think you're
going to get a lot of Wolverine
literally you're going to hear about the
adamantium you're going to hear about
his healing powers and you're going to
hear that Batman is a billionaire who
who pay who has a tricked out suit and I
and I think that you're not I mean we
phrase it as badass and I for me I think
that you have the heavy lifting to do
uh I think you are right about
some of what you said uh I think Batman
does carry a lot more just naturally I'm
doing this so I don't forget and leave
it on the floor but I don't want to put
it in this that's good do it do it all
now I just I'm Gonna
Leave a food wrapper on the floor and it
just made me very nervous I'm sorry I'm
trying to respect you take care of it
after the live show I'm afraid I was
going to forget that hence the term
forget yeah anyway uh we uh do you like
when parents don't feel unconscious when
we argue our bickering is part of it I
just don't remember it was like this I'm
like oh man no we're like two parents
okay good we're just launching into this
point he's starting to participate and
he's like let me crank crack
show and the guests usually do shy with
Sal more than me it's my lot in life I
don't care it's my cross the bear that's
a three that's a 3PO line yeah yeah yeah
it is uh the um no I think that Batman
does have the more immediate
fandom uh or or The Wider breath of
fandom but I think people are a little
DC annoyed at the moment I think they're
a little Batman out and Wolverine's got
a lot of nice heat right now because
there's now uh Jackman is you the 87th
guy to say I'll never play the character
again is coming back now he is in
Deadpool three uh to play Wolverine
again so there's a lot of
cool kid Steam on Wolverine right now
you know so anyway let's start the
battle and let's go
uh ready yeah five two
b-a-t-t-l-e buds
I will open with my argument okay that
Wolverine is not a badass
he's a man going through a midlife
crisis he walks around with his shirt
half buttoned he's got mutton chops
he rides a motorcycle he always has a
cigar the only thing he's missing is a
Maxim magazine peeking out of his back
pocket Wolverine is a corny uncle that
still goes to the club like hey girls
what's going on yeah anybody need me to
buy alcohol he's the creep that would
buy the 16 year old girls beer that's
who Wolverine is
that's my opinion oh x23 who is his
sidekick is a 16 year old girl I think
okay well there you go yeah and if he's
not going through a midlife crisis
because he was born in the 1800s okay
you know your stuff all right like 1883.
so he's just upholding old traditions
having sex with other aged women no no
no he's just he just they fight crime
together or they you know they're just
on a bloodthirsty melee right just a a
death orgy can you go back to that thing
you just had right before this one this
is uh on the internet who is a better
fighter Batman or Wolverine okay we got
Wolverine is stronger much faster
approximately as skilled can only be
taken out by a few specific methods due
to this adamantium and regeneration and
can cut just about anything Batman has
stealth good enough to evade Wolverine's
enhanced senses and enough Tech to hit
above his weight class yeah does that
say to you that they're saying Batman no
I think they're saying it's a pretty
fair fight okay that's that's what I
wanted to convey is that Batman has a
has a mental ability Batman beats
Superman because he know he knew how to
beat Superman well he used Kryptonite
like ruther's been using that for a long
time too but Batman's IQ is supposed to
be around 200. right okay so he's
definitely the smartest woman's age
that's Wolverine's age right right and
Wolverine I mean you have to kind of
take the environment if they are
fighting into question you know what I
mean like if you're fighting in a
warehouse with a bunch of like shipping
containers Batman could operate much
more effectively in stealth mode
right yeah but if you're fighting like
in the streets put them in a prairie
yeah yeah
Wolverine's coming out with claws and
going right at you like you know the
perfect analogy for this battle in my
opinion Mad Max Beyond Thunderdome when
he fights when Mad Max has to fight
Master Blaster Wolverine is Master
Blaster Mad Max is Batman
Wolverine is all brute strength I'm
coming directly at you and I'm going to
clobber you and tear you apart that's
all I know how to do all I know how to
do is hit I can't express my thoughts I
can't use my words I only know violence
Batman is Mad Max where he's like I got
a little whistle that can throw you off
your game because I know your weakness I
use my hooks to get up to the top of
this thing and then repel down yeah but
based on the two things you just said
though because we're not doing who would
win in a fight and based on those two
descriptions you just said for each of
them it sounded like Wolverine is the
bigger badass he's not and here's why
let's just talk plain clothes everyday
life who do you want to hang hang out
with the guy in the leather jacket with
the mutton chops that drives up on his
Harley or the guy that comes in the
Maserati in the three-piece suit that
gets out of the car with three different
well I don't attach value to material
objects that's right that's right
one of those guys one of those guys
shows up at your wedding rehearsal
dinner who one of these scenarios
[Applause]
so if Bruce Wayne and is slick no matter
what so the guy with the mutton chops
and the the adamantium claws that rides
a motorcycle is not the badass and the
guy who can afford lots of gadgets
depends on what your the definition of
badass is but my point is there's a
scenario where Wolverine walks through
the door and you go please get this guy
out of here what are we doing right now
there's no scenario where Bruce Wayne
walks in and you go this is a problem
well this guy is confined the guy is all
class he's classy you know he's not
Rough Around the Edges but I don't know
I don't necessarily attach that to yeah
punched in the face by Spock go back to
that uh pimp I mean
look at that I love it
that's just nonsense
actually check yourself actually it
wasn't a fight it was actually it was
one why does it say pinch oh he he um
you gave him the Vulcan and then Ollie
said it to one Vulcan and Wolverines I
trust I've made my points well you know
if there's a a storyline called Enemy of
the State okay
um it was written by Mark Millar there's
a wolverine story and Elektra found a
way to defeat Wolverine Wolverine was
like uh brainwashed by Hydra in the hand
to be evil and Hydra uh Elektra found a
way to defeat him by taking this her
daggers or her size and put them right
into his uh deltoid like put it right
between the nerves so his healing Factor
couldn't uh help him as quickly so she
found a way to beat him like that so I
think that's what at this fictional
Spock scenario was and keep in mind all
that's fictional real Wolverine right
right I would like the point is though
this is a one-on I'd like to point out
that Elektra was played by Jennifer
Gardner so 13 Going on 30 also took
Wolverine down in a fight I'd like to
put I'd like to point that out right I
don't you know
wife The Woman Batman left
wow you're really coming yeah
oh my uh I didn't know lecture did that
that is very smart I saw Hugh Jackman
out with JLo recently so I don't know
did you just what am I going to say here
I mean I mean if we're going with the
actors you know I I'm going with don't
let him know
just throwing yeah all right what's
going with we're going with law were you
worried about Bruce Wayne coming to his
uh rehearsal dinner yeah I'd keep Bruce
Wayne out of my rehearsal dinner I mean
he's just because you're gonna scheme on
your life yeah no he's got too much
classic guys too much classic but wait
let's actually talk about though because
this does tie into badass because we we
did a battle once on here Luke Skywalker
versus Han Solo
I was Han Solo so I was Luke Luke won I
thought Han Solo would have taken it
easily yeah but
part of that battle was the portrayal of
the character like who is like who is
the cooler more badass guy on on screen
now Wolverine's at a disadvantage
because far less people have portrayed
him yep but
that also leaves the open door for far
more bad people to portray Batman
sure so it goes in both directions but
this is wild what you're showing me
Scrolls from the top
Batman became a vampire and killed
Dracula Batman defeated the Predator yes
yeah Ayatollah Khomeini appointed The
Joker ambassador of Iran
that's from the that's got to be from
the The Joker like 19 like it would
there was the Joker uh solo did you ever
read the oh no that's no I'm wrong I've
got the wrong timeline never mind but
Batman's beating up the predator and uh
he can't be beaten it just who who can't
be beaten Batman a wolverine can't be
beaten Wolverine cannot but you just
said he could Electro beat him in that
one little scenario right because he was
already he was he was brainwashed by
Hydra they needed to have an ending for
that Batman defeated the incredible Bane
Batman beat Bane Bane broke Batman's
back though but then Batman came back
and beat him yeah but like here's the
thing
let's talk about portrayals on screen
okay there's been a lot of lousy Batmans
yes
but
Batman was termed sexually
that's got to be where Ambiguously is
that the psychologist again no no that's
a shocker
um
on screen Hugh Jackman is is great yeah
yeah and I would say you're two great
Batmans on screen are now the Nolan
movies are my favorites but I don't
think Bale is the best Batman I think
that in fact I don't I love bale as
Wayne Bales I don't like his Batman
voice but I like those movies
I think your two best Batmans are
Keaton
and uh Affleck to me is the greatest
ever Batman really I think yeah are you
laughing at this I'm laughing yes
because he doesn't have enough I don't
feel like he established himself I think
he looks great as Batman right and I
think he's I think he's a good Batman
all right right I like Robert Pattinson
as Batman I I hated that movie in ways I
can't even put into words didn't we talk
about we did yeah yeah we went back and
forth about it yeah I liked it for what
it was as a really dark you're like a
more Fiona Apple Style Batman a week no
no no
weak he went into the Iceberg Lounge
beat up the bouncers went and
intimidated penguin uh who is played by
what's his name yeah shoot huge uh Colin
Farrow yeah Colin Farrell he's got a
spin-off show coming up which is going
to be great on HBO Max
yeah I I I love I love an interpretation
of a Peng of the penguin where he looks
like he shops at Men's Warehouse I mean
they took all the ass out of these
characters in that movie but this is
that movie I heard the movie was uh
pretty polarizing I've heard people that
loved it yes I've argued with a lot of
people about it I uh I might have some
attachment to it because I went to see
it with my son is this is the first time
he got to see a a Batman movie on the
big screen like a new back you know what
I mean 14 now so there was a lull in
Batman movies for a long time right and
then we went to see that and he loved it
so I was like you know what I love it
too so that that that's a Brazil because
it speaks to like the 14 year old angsty
mind like like but you can get back to
that that angsty mine when you were 14
and see it for what it is I saw I saw
and I love the I love Adam West I love
it I love Michael Keane
is it Val Kilmer I would say Clooney
Clooney
yeah I thought that was very funny
though yeah but I wanted it to be bail
there was I can guarantee you there is
no way Christopher Nolan is ever going
to let that version of Batman be
tarnished yeah with anything goofy yeah
but but no cloning and kilm I think
Clooney's the worst Batman
nips
yeah but aside from any of that I'm a
huge George Clooney fan I love George
Clooney he's two George Clooney when
he's in the suit so like when he's
talking in the suit you're like that's
George Clooney there is no separation
Keaton even Kilmer who's not one of my
favorite they do a separation like when
they get into the suit and they become
different like Keaton Keaton said some
of his movement had just has to do with
how the suit would let him move but
Keaton is different in the suit it was
one of the only gripes I had about the
his portrayal of Batman again in the
flash was he didn't do the separation
anymore yeah they were like when he was
in the bat yet talking
he just was like I'm going down and I
was like he just sounds like Michael
Keaton right now he's not like locking
into it but Affleck to me is like she's
what it should look like
every part of it to me is the reason
they adopt that that growl is that is
that just so that he's not recognized as
it's kind of like so against glasses
it's in effect yeah on purpose so when
Ben Affleck is like I will be there it's
he's doing that so no one's like it's
freaking yeah Bruce Wayne yeah that's
why that that's that's why that voice
got made fun of so much because they're
like Pete Holmes did a sketch about it
we're we're like out of all the voices
this is what you chose like you know
like you could have done so many but
anyway
Affleck's version of Batman I know this
isn't his call but they had the best
justification of that they had the suit
had a voice
uh like okay destroyed her in it okay so
it dropped his voice and that was only
in that movie and not even in the comic
book ever yeah well I don't know about
that but they only ever did it in the
movies in that one I was like yeah duh
like that's so smart yeah and I used to
thank Darth Vader had the same thing you
know 30 years ago yeah but I mean look
you got Wolverine in a guinea tea
Wolverine is like okay there's that
outfit but then there's also just like
when he's not in that outfit right I
mean let's talk about it he's still him
let's talk about the original Batman he
has to get into the outfit to be badass
you know true yeah well he's badass
let's not uh Square One let's not he's
sort of badass at Square One his claws
don't forget were put into his body
against not his claws but the adamantium
the metal that was put into him against
his will without that metal inner
exoskeleton thing whatever the hell it's
called he has bone claws
and they break and he's weaker he's a
lot weaker so a lot of what wolverine is
no no but yeah a lot of what makes
Wolverine a badass is not a natural
power it's a gadget that's in his body
it is a suit essentially in his body
Batman has a suit Wolverine's powers are
not like Superman's powers where it's
like Superman wore a cape you know what
I mean right am I Am I Wrong Superman's
an alien
Wolverine's a mutant but you get what
I'm saying Wolverine has a Batman style
enhancement with that adamantium sure
but he doesn't have all the the smoke
pellets and the gadgetry that that Bruce
Wayne Batman with Abby doesn't have a
butler he doesn't have a weapons guy man
in the chair got a kid he's got a child
he's got bro Wolverine Batman is a
middle-aged guy yeah right yeah with a
lot of heart which I'll give to you you
know he wants to go out and fight crimes
his parents uh died in crime spoiler
alert guys if you're watching sorry yeah
Batman's parents died
badass who's got a more badass origin
story the guy who witnessed his parents
get murdered and then devoted his life
to learning to live in the shadows and
fight crime or the fop from 1801.
I got into an accident and somehow
can't age past 42.
story
I I think
I think Batman he does have a better
origin story right you know but
you can argue that that Wolverine
coming from Canada
getting subjected to The Weapon X
Program going through all the torture
and torment having these memories put
into his brain serving in the military I
think you've been speaking enough
that's right you stand your ground he's
going to win the argument because he
doesn't stop that's right
yeah his tactics forget it him being him
being from Canada ain't helping your
batteries argument
that's all I wanted to say go ahead okay
no right right right you know I mean
you know and and uh Wolverines from an
actual country you know what I mean it's
addiction and wow you know
uh and I hate arguing against Batman
because I love Batman I love the whole
DC said I don't know why you hate Marvel
though I don't get I don't get that how
can you just hate the entire I don't
like any I don't like any modern there's
very little in modern Comics that I like
anymore not just content wise I don't
like the art style ever since it went to
the digital drawings and all that I just
it looks too shiny and it's just not
interesting to me anymore
so so I'm not big on any real new Comics
uh but
uh Marvel I have grown to strongly
strongly loathe because of the Cinematic
Universe I think that it's become
bloated and gross and it really annoys
me how many actors are part of that
thing that go online and talk about how
much they hate Donald Trump yet
participate in the most capitalistic
empire ever created it's like cool kid
it's like look how many famous
people we fit into at this time guy it's
too much it's like and it's all I hate
all the comedy in it everybody is Tony
Stark now it was I I was with them
hardcore until Avengers 2. and in
Avengers 2 I was like in the theater
going
why is everybody talking like Tony Stark
now like why is Thor making these jokes
those that's not Thor and after that
every Marvel movie was a comedy I don't
want to watch a Thor movie where Asgard
is crumbling and Tahini sauce wakiti
whatever the is the guy that did
what we did in the shadows oh yeah yeah
is doing a character going and he's
making like dumb jokes as the world is
crumbling yeah
uh I feel like Guardians of the Galaxy
the first one which I think is the best
movie of the entire MCU okay wow set the
tone for people started seeing what
James Gunn did and said actually this is
the formula because he was able to bring
you know a uh a tree
a talking raccoon and just you know
obscure characters from from Marvel and
make them sure household names of course
you know and put Chris Pratt on a
different different Stratosphere but the
comedy element combined with the the
rock the soundtrack and everything I
think that pushed that that it's great
in gardening was uh was was Guardians
won before
um uh uh Ryan Reynolds uh for example
yeah I think Deadpool came out after
Deadpool's awesome yeah then here's why
Deadpool is awesome Deadpool is
legitimately funny and the comedy is
inherent to the character and Ryan
Reynolds sells it what Marvel did and
everything else you're right they saw
Guardians of the Galaxy go this is what
you do and it's like well now every
character is the same
I have a bigger gripe with Marvel though
and you're not gonna like this okay they
took
they just steal from I mean DC did it
all first I know you're gonna get mad
but it's true well give me some examples
and then I
uh uh dark side was was preceded Thanos
um
sorry sorry I didn't go to a nerd School
you didn't and then I used to say I used
to say Thanos a lot too before the
movies came out Victorian buddy doing
Patrol preceded X-Men
um uh uh Aquaman proceeded Submariner I
don't know about that it's true no I
think Submariner Deathstroke Deathstroke
proceeded Deadpool it's it dude it's one
the the whole parents dying thing they
just jacked infinite Earth's preceded
spider verse and the Multiverse in
Marvel DC Secret Wars game before a
crisis on infinite Earth though
was in parallel universes right but in
terms of a giant crossover that's what I
I fine but but but but but but
DC has taken or DC has done a lot first
and Marvel has jacked and in fact
Stanley at times has been very kind of
flippant about it Hulk came after um
the thing no the thing is Mom I might be
wrong I thought there was something
because we're getting a little off topic
and we are nearing the end and I've been
eyeing down the phones and I I mean
there is a ton of opinion here okay
there's no shortage of opinion here from
these people so it looks like Batman is
losing right now no there's there's a
wide array Wolverine was in Civil War
and Wars World Wars one and two that's
it was going from before there was just
tons of
just I'm sure that's good good
everywhere but I was reading this is
Canadian upset
Batman has all the superpowers as Elon
Musk oh shut up read it all right sorry
give me the real superhero
whatever that number is uh
thus is hard I do this is hard to do
there's so many good ones up top let's
start a little closer top don't don't
show them picking Batman is the bigger
badass is like saying it's hip to be
square no it's not
uh both are badass however being
badasses Wolverine only
is Wolverine's only real character trait
so he should win
all right
Batman is a regular guy kicking ass
Wolverine has mutant Powers Batman is
way more badass
Batman all the way definitely misread
this is who has the okay
bigger ass uh only a mutant okay
all right yeah all right what is more
badass than metal claws that come out of
your hands a rubber suit with nipples uh
nothing is more badass than metal claws
coming out of your hand Wolverine's hair
is more bad it sounds Wolverine needs
claws but Batman uses money and
Technology to do some real damage he's
sort of a vigilante so Batman has my
voice let's talk about a hell of a
matchup we talking badass have to go
Batman Wolverine gets the job done but
Batman's a bad MF
Batman is just a rich dude with
high-tech weapons I I can I tell you
just real quick can I tell you Wolverine
has no rules Batman does how much I hate
that absorbed opinion about Batman
like I can't stand it Pete Holmes made
that joke 10 years ago and it's like
it's just this become this absorbed
opinion of like it has yeah and I was
afraid it was going to come up today and
and I didn't want to have to rebuke it
or not not that it's to be rebuked but
I'm just I I agree I'm tired of hearing
that as a argument and I didn't notice I
didn't say that
fourth pound of the episode
I don't know what Wolverine's bank
account looks like but he could afford
to go to the school for gifted
youngsters Wolverine is so badass you
made everyone believe the weird little
Badger that a wolverine actually is is
some kind of monstrous wolf creature
that's very funny huge Batman fan but
Wolverine has literal skin and muscle
tissue burn off only to painfully reject
that's a great point and they did that
in the in the Wolverine movie like
you've seen Wolverine have his entire
flesh burnt off yeah and then he grows
it back like that's pretty awesome right
that one right there I love Batman love
Batman literally my favorite hero but
he's not a badass as Wolverine Wolverine
has been through the ringer with that
healing factor of his
Batman and it's not even close with
enough prep time Batman could be the
host of taste buds Wolverine is just
some angry cool dude with metal claws
and insane healing Factor okay
going from Warframe to hero with no true
superpowers or special but it was just
pretty badass
uh Wolverine will eat Batman for
breakfast
ah I mean I I think Wolverine's going to
take this what do you think uh yeah yeah
I think he will you know but but again
as as Sal established it wasn't about
who could win in a fight it's about who
you would want to take to your rehearsal
dinner
well I'm thinking like we're in this big
this big fight you know I I want
Wolverine on my team because he's just
going right out claws out and he's just
we're not more of a badass I would say I
would say as a closing argument
look anytime I play a Marvel video game
which there are many good ones yep
I I take Wolverine every time okay
Marvel vs Capcom he's first guy onto the
team yeah uh the X-Men side scroller
beat him up he's the guy I go with
uh uh
whatever that game is where you can have
the four guy team Gauntlet it's kind of
like Gauntlet no it looks like Gauntlet
actually but it's super it's super what
is that Marvel hero uh whatever the hell
it's called wolverines on the team every
time my point is is I go with Wolverine
time and time again in that setting but
if you told me
hey buddy we're gonna put you up against
another enemy we're not going to tell
you who the enemy is but you have to
pick your ally first there's no way
you're not picking Batman oh I don't
know there's because you got to remember
it might not just be a physical fight
and once you take physical out of it
which is why I'm saying the video game
thing yeah you got some problems with
Wolverine what's he gonna do he's gonna
sit there and complain he's like me he
acts like me I mean do you want that
around do you want that around you
that's not good for morale
Wolverine I guess it's true he has a
motorcycle but he doesn't have his own
mobile Wolverine right I'm sure Hot
Wheels is made of a wolverine mobile at
one point but uh yeah all right so we're
gonna go to uh
uh
oh please oh plug plug away please
before we go okay my closing argument is
that uh oh wait what do you mean
do a closing argument and then plug
whatever you want to play I thought
Batman was great in The Lego Movie
that a little spin-off Will Arnett
another great Batman all right good uh
yeah nah I'm uh I'm plugging zarface you
can do a closing argument and then plug
yeah okay yeah and I I take Wolverine
that's my argument these guys argued for
me
and uh yeah and uh you can find me on
Instagram at Czarface underscore ESO so
Czar f-a-c-e underscore ESO and uh I
want to thank both of you guys all three
of you guys for having me uh having me
on the show thank you for giving us your
time yeah yeah dude it's so cool to have
you yeah thank you yeah go buy their
records guys please I definitely I
definitely wanted to argue about
burritos but um so you got to come back
I'll come back I'll be happy
because I argued against it
there you go well we can always put it
up against us always welcome back
brother thank you all right
we got about 5 000 votes here and uh
pimp is going with Wolverine jump oh
holy
oh my God holy wow now with
something that is I mean we are point
four percent away from each other with
something this close I usually like to
let's just just for fun check back
because it it's a 24-hour poll and then
it closes so 24 like so tomorrow at this
time actually let me log on real quick
it is it is you might tip it right now I
mean it is it is 50 50.3 Batman yes to
49.7 Wolverine is that the closest it's
the second closest ever well we had one
tie we had one legit tie and that I
think is the second closest battle we
have ever had out of the 160 battles or
whatever it is 140 battles
I can't even that means it's a great
battle when it's down the line like that
dude that's point four point three
it's a 0.3 what am I saying it's a point
it's three tenths of a point difference
that's wild isn't that insane hip
refresh it and see if it uh see if it uh
changed I wonder if
okay it's getting it's getting more 0.4
now yeah but honestly I I bet you that
was up and I wonder if because I don't
think necessarily Batman had oh wait a
minute
why is Wolverine oh that's who you voted
for yeah yeah I'm like why is Wolverine
check yeah I thought that too yes holy
well that is sick but we do have
till tomorrow
yeah I honestly well or you just close
it now we close it now but you know you
should look tomorrow because yeah if it
switched the other way you can hang that
over his head for permanently yeah
yeah all right all right we always end
with uh I still love you
yeah and you gotta say I love you too I
do I'm Wolverine would never say that
no I love you too man I gotta be like no
really I really love you that's awesome
great episode
they come into the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to them